lasers! you can use them to cut things
you can use them to point at words
and you can use them to treat about a
million different skin related things
these are just the ones i saw on the aad website
there's different types of pigment and
red marks skin texture loose skin hair
removal and hair regrowth tattoo removal
so how does it work? and does it hurt?
i'm michelle of lab muffin beauty science
chemistry phd and cosmetic chemist and today
we're talking about laser skin treatments i'm
going to cover treating ethnic skin which is
particularly tricky and my own experience
with getting a set of picosure focused
laser treatments what's involved how it
feels whether it hurts and the results
this video is sponsored by cynosure
who make the picosure laser that i
was treated with but as always this is
all my own research and honest opinions
skin care products are great but
there's a limit to how much they can do
and how quickly they can work
in-clinic treatments can be a better
option for a lot of things and laser
treatments are one of the most popular as
you can tell from the giant list lasers are
incredibly versatile this isn't a complete list
and lasers aren't necessarily the only or the
best treatment for a lot of these but it gives you
an idea of the massive range we're talking about
so what is a laser a laser is a machine that
shoots out light now it's not the same as a
torch the light has special properties that make
it really good for skin treatments the light is
very aligned and in sync so the light is very
energetic and focused into a tiny area it's also
one color the light is a particular wavelength
having just the one color of light means that
you can target specific things in the skin with
minimal impact on everything else in the skin
so you shoot light into the skin with a laser and
then something in the skin will absorb the light
and when stuff absorbs light it converts
it to other forms of energy like heat
if you put a black thing and a white thing
in the sun the black thing heats up more
because black dye absorbs more light energy and
turns it into more heat different things absorb
different wavelengths of light so if you shoot
a particular wavelength of light into the skin
a particular colour of light that melanin pigment
absorbs but other things don't really then that
means the melanin pigment gets blasted but other
things in your skin don't they have minimal damage
and most lasers work pretty much like
different colored things in the sun
the melanin heats up while the
rest of your skin stays mostly cool
this is called selective
photothermolysis you can select
one thing and use light to heat it up until
it breaks the thing that absorbs the light
the thing in your skin that the laser
is targeting is called the chromophore
apart from melanin the other chromophores in the
skin that lasers usually target are haemoglobin
the red chemical in red blood cells and water
so to remove brown pigment patches lasers
target melanin to remove red things like broken
capillaries the lasers are targeting haemoglobin
skin has a lot of water in it so
the lasers that target water cause
controlled damage to the skin in general
so that hopefully gets the skin to repair
itself in a good way like with more
collagen in a rejuvenating treatment
or to smooth out the surface and reduce fine
lines and scars which is called laser resurfacing
different wavelengths also travel
different distances into the skin
longer wavelengths get deeper into the skin so
longer wavelengths are used in laser hair removal
they can get down deep enough to heat
up and kill cells in the hair root which
is all the way down here in the dermis for
epidermal pigment that's a lot more shallow
in the skin you can use shorter wavelengths
that don't have to get down quite as far
apart from wavelength or colour there are tons of
other settings that can be adjusted to change how
a laser works on the skin there's the pattern of
the light whether it's a continuous beam of light
or whether it's short pulses how long each of
those short pulses are the gap between the pulses
how much the beam is spread out and having so
many options means that laser results will depend
a lot on the skills of the person
who's using the laser on you
that's why it's really important to research
properly before booking into a laser treatment
that also means there is this massive
range of how intense laser treatments are
i think a lot of us including me get a bit
scared when we think about laser treatments
we think about lightsabers and laser eye
surgery and pictures of people with scabby
red skin hiding in the dark for a week after
their treatment and yes this is one form of
laser treatment this is called ablative laser
which means that it purposely damages the top
layer of skin in a controlled way and this
can give really dramatic results that's why
people are willing to put up with a week of being
scabby and it can take months to finish healing
but now we also have much gentler laser
treatments that don't have this long downtime
and they're also less risky especially for people
with darker skin one of the biggest problems with
laser treatments when it comes to people with
asian skin like mine or mediterranean skin
or darker so most people in the world is that
our skin responds to trauma by producing pigment
this is called post-inflammatory hyperpigmentation
or pih so if you're using a laser to try to blast
away pigment which we often are because uneven
pigmentation is one of the main ways our skin ages
there is a big risk of causing so much trauma
that you make more pigment form which is the
exact opposite of what you want to happen
you don't want to blast away a patch of
pigment and get the same patch back or an
even bigger patch this is called rebound
pigmentation and it used to be a massive
risk for people with darker skin when they
had more aggressive treatments like laser but
there's been newer lasers developed that can
treat darker skin effectively with a much
lower risk of getting that rebound pigment
one of the most popular lasers is the
picosure focus which is the machine that
i was treated with at neutral bay dermatology
the picosure focus has two special features
firstly there is a really short pulse duration
which means it fires really short blasts of
light into the skin the pico part refers
to picoseconds which is how short these
blasts of light are each one lasts less than
1 billionth of a second and that means there
isn't really much time for heat to build up
and damage the surrounding bits of skin and
trigger that rebound pigment it's kind of
like when you take something really hot out
of the microwave and you're too lazy to get
a towel if you go fast enough and you don't
touch it for too long then there's not enough
time for heat to build up and give you a burn
it also turns out that having these really short
laser pulses means it works a bit differently in
your skin traditional lasers mostly work by
heating up the pigment until it breaks up
but with picosecond lasers the light turns
into sound instead of heat and the pressure
waves from the sound mechanically shatters the
pigment particles so you can get really effective
breaking up of the pigment without the same
amount of heat and that risk of rebound pigment
these pressure waves also have a skin rejuvenating
effect so they stimulate collagen and elastin in
the dermis and that means you can get plumper
skin and smoothing out of fine lines and wrinkles
and shallow scarring and because melanin
is what's turning the light into pressure
it actually works better on melanated skin
this picosecond laser technology was actually
first developed for tattoo removal and it's only
really become popular for skin treatments in the
last five years or so it's really cool because
it's made it a lot easier for skin clinics to
treat ethnic skin more effectively and more safely
the other special feature of the picosure laser
is the focused lens array which is a fractionating
head what this means is that it splits up the
laser beam into lots of little concentrated dots
so instead of treating one big patch of skin
you're treating lots of little columns of skin
again this means the heat builds up less
if we go back to the analogy of taking
hot stuff out of the microwave when you're
lazy it's like how you try to hold it with
little spread out claws so that there's
lots of space for the heat to dissipate
this also means that you can deliver a lot more
power safely so there's 20 times the amount of
power compared to the original picosure so
it makes it more effective while also being
safer and so all of this means that the picosure
focus is really good for treating ethnic skin
before the treatment you'll still have
to avoid tanning both real and fake
because it'll get in the way of the laser but
you don't have to avoid harsh skin care for
quite as long i only had to stop using chemical
exfoliants and retinoids for a couple of days
for more intense treatments you might need
to stop using them for a few weeks plus you
also might need to avoid some medications
like ibuprofen that can cause bruising
now during the treatment the picosure
treatment is really gentle and painless
as far as lasers go now i am a massive
wuss when it comes to laser treatments
the doctors and nurses at neutral bay dermatology
were really lovely and they reassured me that most
people don't feel much they offered me numbing
cream anyway and i took it because i figured
i'd rather have it and not need
it than chicken out in the middle
here i am looking like the weeknd waiting
for it to set in if you go for the cream
you'll have to turn up about half an hour
early they also blow cold air onto your
face during the treatment and that numbs your
face as well as reducing the risk of damage
with all of this numbing and cold air the
laser felt like a tiny little rubber band
snapping gently against my skin snapping a bit
harder in places where i had pigment the laser
felt a lot more annoying than actually painful
and i found that with the nurse talking to me
the whole time to distract me it was very
bearable and the treatment was over really
quickly it only takes about 10 minutes the
snapping sound that you can hear is actually
the pigment breaking up i tried the laser on
my not numb hand later and it felt fine so
i think i didn't really need the cream but from
past experience i've learned that when a medical
professional gives me painkillers i should always
say yes so base it on your own pain tolerance
obviously after the treatment
my face was still super numb
if you go in without any numbing it feels like
a slight sunburn they gave me two ice packs to
hold on my face for 10 minutes to soothe
the skin and reduce the chance of swelling
now probably the coolest thing about the picosure
is that you have virtually zero downtime so in
other words you can face the world and do all
your usual things pretty much immediately there's
no flaking or peeling or scabbing your skin
might look a little bit redder afterwards but
it should go away after a couple of hours my skin
looked completely normal you could barely tell i
had anything done at this stage you might also
see that your pigment is actually a bit darker
and that's because the pigment is more spread
out from all of that shattering the pigment
might get darker for the next 24 hours and then
over the next one to two weeks the pigment will
actually travel up and shed along with your
normal skin cells which are turning over
in terms of results the picosure is also quite
fast you should see pretty significant changes
after the first treatment but usually for
dealing with pigment and texture and sun
damage it takes two to four treatments the
treatments should be about two to four weeks
apart so that your skin has time to shed
the pigment before you get blasted again
here are my results after two treatments
i couldn't get the photos after the third
treatment because we went into lockdown you
can see that even with just two treatments
the pigment's faded quite a bit on my
cheeks and on the bridge of my nose
it's a bit harder to see but the pores
and texture are also a lot softer
the picosure is the most popular picosecond
laser so it's been used effectively on millions
of people around the world there's a lot
of research around it there are lots of
clinical trials using the picosure and you'll
be able to find lots of before and after photos
i'm going to be honest with you i was pretty
hesitant to get these laser treatments at first
because i am just so pathetic when
it comes to painful skin treatments
i've turned down quite a few free laser treatments
before because i was just so worried about the
pain but my experience with the picosure was
really good it was way gentler than i thought
laser could actually be it's definitely
changed my mind about laser treatments
and i would happily do it again which is not
something i thought i would ever say about laser
so i hope you learned something from
this video like and subscribe if you
like skincare and science and
click the nerdification bell